if you've ever wondered how superheroes
manage to do all that heroic stuff while
wearing those wildly impractical
costumes you're not alone in fact some
of the actors playing these heroes on
the big screen had major issues with
their outfits here's a look at some
actors who despise their superhero
costumes Jennifer Lawrence that blue
body paint the Jennifer Lawrence wears
and the x-men films may look cool but
Jayla herself isn't a huge fan
considering it took a whopping seven
hours to apply when she filmed x-men
first class
not to mention all those if he's
chemicals she told Entertainment Weekly
that she worries about the fumes and
toxins now that she's older I'm almost
25 and I'm like I can't even pronounce
this and that's going in my nose I'm
breathing that luckily the makeup
process was cut down to approximately
three hours for Days of Future past an
apocalypse thanks in part to a new
bodysuit they created that's evolution
in action Ron Perlman
j-law isn't the only hero who's sick of
the makeup chair Ron Perlman had to
endure marathon sessions for his role as
Hellboy as it took between four and
seven hours for him to get ready every
time thanks to use of old-school
prosthetics rather than CGI in fact
director Guillermo del Toro tells
Benedict that Perlman Teichert of the
costume is one major reason there hasn't
been a third Hellboy film
he grew really tired of the makeup in
the second film and he was really rubbed
the wrong way by those seven-hour
session sounds like hell boy Ryan
Reynolds unlike many superhero movie
stars Ryan Reynolds didn't have to go
through an arduous process to get in
costume for Green Lantern thanks to the
fact that his suit was mostly done with
CGI
so why does Reynolds hate the costume
because it looks crappy and he loathes
the movie I would I would give it a
scamp or you give it a pill three or
four doesn't really work I'm better yeah
one it's a lot how much did he dislike
his costume in the green lantern he even
made fun of it on-screen and it's hit
superhero parodies Deadpool and please
don't make the supersuit green or
animated all Bettany back when he was
providing the voice of Tony Stark's
Jarvis computer guy in the Iron Man
films Paul Bettany said he felt like a
pirate because the voice over work was
so easy it was like stealing money well
he quickly learned that he was going to
have to earn his money as the vision
because now that he's on screen he has
to endure his own uncomfortable costume
which he told USA Today takes three and
a half hours to put on by the fourth and
fifth day of the week you are really
having to meditate on the line of actors
thousands of them who would love to be
in your position you have to concentrate
on how lucky you are
Christian Bale with three Batman movies
under his utility belt Christian Bale is
something of an expert on the importance
of a comfortable costume after enduring
a terribly constricting and painful suit
for Batman Begins Bale requested a new
suit for the Dark Knight resulting in
more fluid action scenes and a more
relaxed filming experience but its
biggest piece of advice for future bad
men like Ben Affleck make sure your bat
suit has a zipper on it the only thing I
said to him is look just make sure he
could take a piss without anyone having
to help him because it's a little bit
humiliating I went through when you have
to have somebody's not gonna help you
out Val Kilmer if only Christian Bale
had been around to share that bit of
potty advice to Val Kilmer turns out
Kilmer who played the Caped Crusader in
1995 Batman Forever also had major
issues with the costume including an
unfortunate inability to use the
restroom alone he likened wearing his
suit which took an hour to put on to
living in an old folks home I realized
one day what wearing that suit was like
it was oh this is what being old feels
like no one really listens to you
anymore
you can't really talk or hear you're
always falling over and someone has to
help you go to the bathroom and get
dressed and hathaway some superhero
costumes are uncomfortable and then
there's the signature skin type suit and
heels of Catwoman which is even more
uncomfortable mentally than physically
for Dark Knight Rises star Anne Hathaway
as she explained in an interview with
lure
costume was a psychological terrorist
the suit thoughts of my suit changing my
life so I would fit into that suit it
dominated my year I went to the gym for
ten months and didn't come out Robert
Downey jr. as you've probably learned by
now it's tough being a superhero
something Robert Downey jr. learned the
hard way when he stepped into the role
of Ironman I've been training all these
years and thought it was pretty tough
but the first time I put on the mark one
suit I almost had a personality meltdown
I'm not claustrophobic but after moving
around in it for a couple of hours your
spirit is kind of broken and you're like
okay time to bring in the stunt team
fortunately these days most of the time
Marvel Studios is able to render the
suit with CGI rather than grape jelly
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to